[Musica]
mi sono in ruanda poco più di un anno fa
sono circondato da bambini come vedete
davanti a me una delle nature più belle
che abbia visto mai in vita mia mi
ricorda che a un certo momento mi sono
fermato a guardare l'orizzonte e ho
pensato che se 12 anni fa mi avessero
detto che sarei stato qui e soprattutto
se mi avessero detto che nel giro di
pochi anni avrei preso più di 200 aerei
e visitato 20 delle popolazioni più
povere del mondo
ecco io non ci avrei creduto perché non
aveva mai creduto di essere lì e
soprattutto non aver mai pensato di
esserci ancora
questa è una storia che parla di tempo
un tempo che avevo e che pensavo fosse
limitato stavo per compiere quarant'anni
mi sentivo onnipotente perché il
protagonista della vita ero io avevo una
bellissima famiglia anzi una bellissima
casa famiglia quattro figli e tanti
altri figli accolti aveva un lavoro che
mi dava tante soddisfazioni
era un personaggio conosciuto e stimato
per il suo impegno politico
e sapete quanto è difficile oggi essere
stimato per quello
insomma ci sono quei momenti in cui tu
pensi che qualsiasi obiettivo e hai
davanti tu lo possa raggiungere e
soprattutto tu pensi che il tempo
davanti a te sia è limitato ecco io ero
così mi sentivo immortale
poi a un certo punto incomincia a
dimagrire e all'inizio era anche
contento perché la linea era sicuramente
migliore poi al dimagrimento ci sono
associati dei dolori sempre più forti
lancinanti finché sono stato ricoverato
d'urgenza per una occlusione intestinale
e lì il primo responso signor vitali
lei ha un tumore all'inizio pensavano
fosse una cosa semplice tanto è vero che
la prima dottoressa che ho incontrato
che sembrava uscita da un film di
fellini addirittura l'aveva chiamato to
morino come se fosse una cosa simpatica
in realtà alla parte del giorno dopo
il chirurgo scopre vede che non era così
semplice anzi era molto complicato e non
lo sapeva quale fosse potesse essere il
decorso ma credo che neanche lui si
aspettasse di trovare quello che ha
visto quando mi ha operato e quando è
uscito dalla sala operatoria incontrato
mia moglie e con la sua il tatto che che
gli era riconosciuto gli ha detto
signora abbiamo fatto il possibile
non c'è più niente da fare mi raccomando
non fatelo girare per ospedali
lasciatelo morire in pace a casa
ecco io quella verità l'ho scoperta
qualche giorno dopo perché dovevo andare
a fare una radiografia in un altro
reparto
e allora da chirurgia mi consegnano la
cartella clinica
una cosa che non si fa mai quei pazienti
mai e era in carrozzina mia moglie mi
spingeva e quindi avuto tutto il tempo
di leggere quella cartella
insomma di referto post operatorio era
la descrizione di una battaglia e anche
se c'erano dei pannoloni medici
importanti anche un ignorante come me
riusciva a capirne il significato
era la descrizione di una battaglia che
stava per essere persa ecco quel referto
aveva lasciato la mia mente soprattutto
il mio corpo ha lasciato dei grossi
problemi
tant'è vero che io sono immediatamente è
svenuto mentre facevo la radiografia e
mi sono risvegliato nel mio letto di
ospedale solo solo con quella angosce
che quell effetto mi aveva scatenato
cavoli stefano non hai più tempo
dobbiamo solo capire quanto me ne era
rimasto però non avevo il coraggio di
affrontare questo con né con i medici e
soprattutto con mia moglie perché in
ogni caso non avrei sopportato nella
verità e neanche le bugie loro in fondo
sapevano
però mi avevano ottenuto volontariamente
in quel limbo in cui poi la verità tela
costruisci da solo quella è stata la più
lunga notte della mia vita perché poi
avevo una vocina in testa oltretutto
anche antipatica che mi ripeteva sempre
la stessa frase il tempo a sua
disposizione sta per terminare
game over come game over
sono nè di quello che fino a una
settimana prima pensava di essere
immortale non eri quello che pensava di
poter spaccare il mondo e soprattutto
non eri quello che aveva zero sensi di
colpa quando dedicava poco tempo ai suoi
figli per il lavoro perché tanto quel
tempo avrebbe potuto recuperare non
stefano no non sei più quello non sei
immortale e soprattutto non hai più
tempo
lo ripeto quella è stata la notte più
lunga della mia vita però come credo che
capiti anche ognuno di voi con le luci
edicole prime luci del giorno quelle
nebbie si sono quelle ombre oscure ce ne
sono andate via piano piano
e allora nella mia testa c'era un'altra
voce che stavolta più simpatica di
quella di prima che mi ripeteva una
frase in maniera sempre più prepotente
fino a farlo a diventare quasi un urlo
liberatorio no cazzo te la faccia sudare
ecco scusate il francesismo ma in quella
tela faccia sudare
c'era tutta la mia voglia di rimettermi
in gioco tutta la mia voglia di vivere
quel tempo qualunque esso fosse stato
giocando in attacco perché prima del
game over
c'era un'altra partita più importante da
giocare che era quella di vivere quel
tempo rimasto con dignità e soprattutto
in maniera positiva ed è per quello che
tutte le mattine ogni volta che mi
svegliavo in mi ripetevo sempre la
stessa frase stefano devi indossare il
tuo sorriso più bello
avevo voglia di tornare a casa di
rivedere la mia famiglia di stati come i
figli di recuperare quel tempo che avevo
perso in quei giorni mi ricordo che ho
notato tanti particolari delle persone a
me care che prima non avevo visto
atteggiamenti e sorrisi e abbracci
era come se li vedessi per la prima
volta ed erano bellissimi e poi avevo un
altro obiettivo che volevo portare a
casa che era l'unica eredità che avrei
potuto lasciare i miei figli che era
quella di far vedere che un padre può
affrontare la malattia e morire con
dignità col sorriso
ecco allora se vuoi fare questo deve
incominciare a vivere il tempo
intensamente e se lo vive intensamente
riesce a goderti addirittura l'istante e
se vivi l'istante quel tempo si dilata
diventa maggiore poi comincia a fare
chemioterapia e quando entrò per la
prima volta nel day hospital oncologico
capisco che avevo un altro obiettivo da
portare a casa che era quello di far
capire ai miei nuovi compagni di viaggio
i pazienti come me quello che io avevo
capito perché chi entra in quel reparto
sa che la prima cosa che incontra sono
gli occhi gli occhi delle persone che
stanno facendo terapia che sono sempre
tristi disperati sono gli occhi delle
persone che sanno che il futuro che
erano davanti è limitato ecco io volevo
gridare a loro che anche loro glielo
dovevano far sudare e non potevo farlo
con le parole non sarebbero servite lo
dovevo fare solo esclusivamente col mio
atteggiamento e dovrà essere sempre un
atteggiamento positivo sorridente a
volte anche dissacratorio perché mi
ricordo che in un periodo in quel
periodo soprattutto al lavoro io mi
facevo chiamare il tool morato di dio
era un modo per scherzare sulla malattia
era un modo per renderla quasi e
simpatica ecco però non crediate che
fosse
tutto semplice perché poi tornava la
notte con una notte tornava nelle
angosce e paure che però come sempre
alle prime luci del giorno svanivano
perché in fondo aveva una missione da
compiere che era quella di
riappropriarmi dei miei affetti e di
aiutare le persone che come me
stavano vivendo la malattia poi
esattamente tre mesi dopo l'operazione
il primario di oncologia mi chiama nel
suo ufficio e mi dice stefano non
chiedermi perché perché ti giuro che non
lo so ma i tuoi valori sono tornati
nella norma
la prima reazione ovviamente è stata
quella di gioia però subito dopo vi
garantisco subito dopo c'è stata una
domanda e adesso perché adesso sei fra
il frastornato e l'esaltato frastornato
perché cavoli e adesso come riorganizza
la mia vita
esaltato perché te la puoi riorganizzare
e quindi il tempo ricomincia a scorrere
anzi ri comincia a scorrere veloce e
allora che senso a vivere l'istante
quando il tempo ce l'hai e quindi
ritorni ad essere onnipotente
addirittura ti candidi e diventi
presidente della provincia perché vedete
ognuno di noi nelle avversità fa 10.000
propositi ma ogni volta che diversità
scompaiono anche i nostri propositi
scompaiono
siamo fatti così io però ho avuto la
fortuna di continuare a fare per quattro
anni chemioterapia
perché in realtà i medici non sapendo
perché ero guarita una conte hanno
continuato a buttarmi dentro roba e di
avere poi la consapevolezza maturata
piano piano che nella mia guarigione
c'era poco o nulla di normale anzi
parlandole con le statistiche mediche
nelle guarigioni del tipo di tumore che
avevo io
io sono l'unico
che poteva e oggi può ancora parlarne
ecco frequentare ancora per quattro anni
il day hospital oncologico e avere la
consapevolezza di essere un
sopravvissuto ne hanno fatto
riappropriare del concetto di tempo di
come lo vivevo durante la malattia e
soprattutto mi hanno fatto tornare in
mente la stessa domanda che mi facevo
quando stavo male
ora però me la facevo con un significato
completamente diverso perché a me perché
quando frequentate e ospitano oncologico
incontrate decine di persone che alla
fine non ce la fanno
pensate a un treno
abbiamo tutti lo stesso biglietto e
tutti la stessa destinazione però in
realtà ogni tanto questo treno si ferma
e qualcuno è costretto a scendere anche
se non vuole
e tu quel viaggio invece lo continui sia
ancora su quel treno anzi un giorno
stavi per scendere ma se è risalito
velocemente
e allora perché io sto continuando quel
viaggio perché sono ancora su quel treno
perché non c'è quel padre di famiglia
che magari aveva dei figli che avranno
più bisogno dei miei di avere un padre
in vita o quel ragazzo di 28 anni o quei
tanti altri che tu hai incontrato
ecco quel perché a me ti fa tornare in
testa prepotentemente il valore del
tempo e soprattutto ti fa capire che non
puoi essere più tu a gestire il tempo
secondo quello che tu vuoi ma devi
gestire o secondo quello che ti viene
richiesto di fare è un cambiamento di
prospettiva e per quello che vi dicevo
all'inizio che non avere non avrei mai
pensato di essere qui e non avrei mai
pensato di esserci ancora non avete
pensato di esserci ancora penso che
abbiate capito no perché
ecco invece sul fatto di essere qui è
molto più semplice perché io sono
riminese
anzi mia sono stato presentato come
riminese doc e come tutti i riminesi e
la mia vita l'ho sviluppata tra il cardo
e il decumano noi siamo quelli che
pensano che i confini della provincia
sia nei confini del mondo
c'è addirittura chi pensa che rimini sia
il mondo per noi andare a bologna
all'università è un viaggio lontano
ecco è per questo che quando mi hanno
proposto di seguire i progetti
all'estero della comunità papa giovanni
con condivisione fra i popoli
io ho subito detto no non posso
viaggiare non posso andare oltre le
comodità non posso farle file per me
fare un viaggio andare già oltre il
ponte di tiberio però mia moglie mi ha
fatto ragionare mi ha detto stefano
almeno provaci
non puoi dire subito no io in realtà
avevo già la consapevolezza che dovevo
lasciarmi guidare ed è per quello che un
mese dopo esattamente un mese dopo io
ero in tanzania
il primo viaggio quella consapevolezza
però che aveva trovato una scusa per che
quello fosse anche l'ultimo ne avrei
potuto trovare tante
pensate a fare 10 ore in un pullman
africano e tre posti con un odore
indescrivibile con la faccia spiaccicata
alla fine siano perché 1t dorme sulla
spalla per tutto il viaggio
e tu non è neanche il coraggio di
svegliarlo ecco io ad alta però in quel
viaggio mi sono innamorato degli occhi
prima degli occhi di un bambino dei
bambini che sono sempre felici
sorridenti che giocano con niente si
divertono con niente e ringrazia una
volta di quel niente
poi gli occhi degli adulti pieni di
rabbia iniettati di sangue di quella
rabbia che di chi sa che non che il
futuro davanti non esiste che solo
disperazione è qui e lì che ho capito il
senso del mio viaggio
volevo fare in modo che quegli occhi
diventassero i miei occhi che quella
rabbia diventasse la mia rabbia perché
in fondo volevo cambiare il destino di
quelle persone non perché ero il più
bravo ma perché avevo capito che era
giusto così perché non potevo rimanere
indifferente perché non poteva non
pensare che il cambiamento di quelle
persone passasse anche da me
ecco il viaggio in tanzania per me è
ancora il viaggio perché io volevo
mettermi in mezzo quegli occhi
volevo creare un ponte di speranza
perché gli occhi di quel bambino una
volta diventato grande e rimanessero
uguali perché poi quegli occhi ti
sfidano degli impegni nei confronti di
quegli occhi perché ogni volta che
incontri quegli occhi incontri storiche
sono diverse pensate la mamma ho visto
un giorno una mamma in zambia che
entrava in un centro nutrizionale quella
sua bambina in braccio stava piangendo
la disperata mi hanno subito detto che
quella bambina era la gemella di una
sorella morta poco tempo prima di
malnutrizione in fondo sua mamma ci
chiedeva in maniera disperata di fare in
modo che quella bambina sopravvivesse e
allora tu li capisci che non sei lì solo
per dar da mangiare a quella bambina ma
per fare in modo che quella mamma possa
un giorno avere la possibilità di
garantire il futuro e proprio figlio e
allora pensi a un progetto pensi a come
fare a far sì che quella norma possa
lavorare e quindi il viaggio si porta
dietro un'altra tappa che il viaggio
prossimo per andare a vedere se quella
mamma ce l'ha fatta e se quella bambina
è ancora viva
chi salva una vita salva il mondo intero
dice un detto israeliano qui non si
tratta di salvare il mondo
si tratta solamente di salvare quello
sguardo quegli occhi viaggiare oggi per
me non è un abitudine viaggiate per me
oggi è un bisogno bisogno di conoscere
culture diverse dalla mia bisogno di
farmi mettere continuamente in
discussione non avere certezze
accarezzando
una pelle diversa dalla mia perché
vedete su quel treno di prima
non ci sono solo più persone che
scendono ma ce ne sono tante altre che
salgono io ogni giorno mi chiedo perché
a me e vi giuro che non lo so forse
perché serviva a me perché senza quello
che mi è successo il nostro stefano di
oggi
ripeto non il più bravo ma quello che ha
una consapevolezza diversa di quello che
gli sta intorno
io non so ancora perché a me l'unica
cosa che so è che non posso più sprecare
il mio tempo e soprattutto non posso più
dire a nessuno guarda non ho tempo
perché il tempo è un dono e quando tu
riceve un regalo devi dire semplicemente
grazie
i bambini in ruanda direbbero mura cose
[Applauso]